>> WE NOW CALL IT SPYGATE.
YOU ARE CALLING IT SPYGATE.
A LOT OF BAD THINGS HAVE
HAPPENED.
I WANT THEM ALL TO GET TOGETHER.
THEY WILL SIT IN THE ROOM.
HOPEFULLY THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
WORK IT OUT AMONG THEMSELVES.
WE ARE NOT UNDERCUTTING.
WE'RE CLEANING EVERYTHING UP.
WHAT I WANT IS TOTAL
TRANSPARENCY.
>> ANY MEETING BETWEEN THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT ON
CAPITOL HILL ABOUT SUCH
INFORMATION SHOULD ONLY BE
ATTENDED BY MEMBERS OF THE GANG
OF EIGHT.
>> I DON'T CARE WHO COMES.
I AM NOT IN CONTROL OF THE
INVITE LIST.
>> Bret: WELL, THIS MEETING IS
GOING FORWARD.
WE MENTIONED IN EARLIER WITH
JOHN ROBERTS.
THE MEETING TOMORROW WILL
INCLUDE THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN DEVIN NUNES.
HOUSE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN TREY GOWDY.
FBI DIRECTOR, NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE DIRECTOR AND ACTING
PRINCIPAL DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
ALL OF THOSE WILL BE AT THE
MEETING AT THE DOJ ABOUT THE
CLASSIFIED ELEMENTS OF THIS
INVESTIGATION.
WE ARE BEING TOLD THERE WILL
LIKELY BE ANOTHER MEETING WITH
THE GANG OF EIGHT, THE
BIPARTISAN LEADERSHIP OF
CONGRESS.
POSSIBLY AFTER THE MEMORIAL DAY
RECESS.
WE WILL START THERE WITH ALL OF
THIS INVESTIGATION OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
JOINING ME IN LOS ANGELES, STEVE
HILTON, FORMER ADVISOR TO
BRITISH PRIME MINISTER DAVID
CAMERON AND HOST OF "THE NEXT
REVOLUTION."
LESLIE MARSHALL, SYNDICATED TALK
RADIO HOST.
IN WASHINGTON, MARA LIASSON,
NATIONAL POLITICAL CORRESPONDENT
OF NATIONAL PUBLIC RADIO.
MATTHEW CONTINUITY, EDITOR IN
CHIEF OF "THE WASHINGTON
FREE BEACON."
STEVE, YOUR THOUGHTS ON HOW THIS
IS COMING OUT AND SIGNIFICANCE.
>> IT WASN'T THAT LONG AGO THAT
THE LEFT AND PARTS OF THE
ESTABLISHMENT MEDIA,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," WERE
DEEPLY SUSPICIOUS OF WHAT WE NOW
DESCRIBE AS A DEEP STATE.
WE HAD JAMES CLAPPER GOING TO
CONGRESS AND LYING ABOUT
SURVEILLING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THERE IS A SUSPICION OF THE
SECURITY SERVICES AND
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES.
NOW THAT THEY SEEM TO BE AGAINST
ROME, WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE
THEY ARE PURE THAN PURE.
THERE'S NO QUESTION THERE ARE
SUFFICIENT REASONS TO THINK THAT
THE ESTABLISHMENT THOUGHT THAT
THE PROSPECT OF A TRUMP
PRESIDENCY WAS UNTHINKABLE,
UNACCEPTABLE, AND TOOK STEPS TO
TRY TO STOP IT.
THERE'S ENOUGH SUSPICION THERE
TO THINK THAT WE REALLY DO NEED
A THOROUGH INVESTIGATION THAT'S
EQUIVALENT TO THE INVESTIGATION
AND RUSSIAN MEDDLING, WHICH IS
REALLY IMPORTANT, TO LOOK AT THE
POTENTIAL OF DEEP STATE
MEDDLING.
>> Bret: MARA, ARE YOU CALLING
IT SPYGATE?
THE PRESIDENT IS HAPPY THAT HE
HAS BRANDED SOMETHING NEW.
HE HAS COME UP WITH SPYGATE.
HE SAID YOU ARE CALLING IT
SPYGATE.
EVERYONE IS TALKING ABOUT IT.
HE SAID IT COULD BE THE BIGGEST
SCANDAL IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
BUT HE IS TALKING ABOUT IS THAT
THERE WAS SOMEONE, A SPY, AS HE
CALLS IT, EMBEDDED IN HIS
CAMPAIGN FOR POLITICAL PURPOSES
TO SPY ON THE CAMPAIGN.
SO FAR THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF
THAT.
WE DON'T KNOW IF HE'S TALKING
ABOUT AN FBI INFORMANT
ABOUT AN FBI INFORMANT WHO MET
WITH CERTAIN MEMBERS OF THE
CAMPAIGN, REACHED OUT TO THEM TO
FIND OUT WHAT CONTACTS THEY HAD
WITH RUSSIANS.
BUT IF THE PRESIDENT WANTED TO,
HE CAN DECLASSIFY ANY PIECE OF
INFORMATION HE WANTS.
HE COULD HAVE ASKED ANY OF HIS
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS OVER THE
LAST COUPLE WEEKS OR MONTHS TO
SAY TELL ME WHAT YOU KNOW.
WAS THERE A SPY EMBEDDED IN MY
CAMPAIGN?
I DON'T THINK HE WANTS TO KNOW.
I THINK HE WANTS TO KEEP THE
STORY GOING.
IT'S A GOOD NARRATIVE FOR HIM
AND IT HELPS HIM UNDERMINE THE
CREDIBILITY OF THE
INVESTIGATIONS INTO HIM AND HIS
CAMPAIGN.
>> Bret: I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
ANOTHER DEVELOPMENT, LESLIE, THE
JARED KUSHNER GETTING SECURITY
CLEARANCE TODAY FINALLY AFTER A
LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
NATIONAL SECURITY LAW ATTORNEY
TOLD US "THIS IS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT DEVELOPMENT.
THE BUREAU WOULD'VE HAD VERY
SENIOR PEOPLE ON THIS IN THE
MATTER WOULD'VE BEEN REVIEWED
AND APPROVED OF THE MOST SENIOR
LEVELS.
THIS DECISION WILL BE HIGHLY
VETTED AND CONSIDERED.
THEY WOULDN'T BE DEEMING HIM
ELIGIBLE FOR ACCESS TO
CLASSIFIED MATERIALS NO MATTER
WHAT LEVEL OF CLEARANCE IF THERE
WERE ANY OUTSTANDING
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE CONCERNS
WHATSOEVER."
ONE PERSON'S ASSESSMENT.
YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> I DON'T THINK JARED KUSHNER
IS THE PROBLEM.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
RHETORIC ARE THE PROBLEM AND
IT'S CAUSED A PROBLEM NOT ONLY
FOR HIS SON-IN-LAW BUT THAT
TENSION WE HAVE SEEN WITH THE
RHETORIC TOWARD THE FBI AND
OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO BE WORKING
FOR OUR COUNTRY AND FOR THE
CONSTITUTION.
WHEN WE GO BACK TO MARA'S
POINTS, WHEN YOU CALL THE
SPYGATE, AND I'M NOT CALLING IT
SPYGATE.
I WANT TO GO ON THE RECORD.
>> Bret: I DON'T THINK WE HAVE
CALLED IT SPYGATE.
>> LET'S SPEAK ABOUT SPYGATE, IF
WE WILL.
THE RULE OF THE FBI, ANYBODY,
EVEN IF THEY WORKED FOR
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENTS, THIS
GENTLEMAN ALL THE WAY BACK TO
RONALD REAGAN, IS TO DO EXACTLY
THIS BREEDS TO SAY THERE'VE BEEN
SOME CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN
RUSSIA AND THOSE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
PAUL MANAFORT HAS BEEN INDICTED.
PAUL MANAFORT IS ONE OF THE
PEOPLE WHO WERE SPOKEN TO AND TO
MARA'S POINT, THE PRESIDENT HAS
THE POWER TO FIND OUT IF THERE
WAS A SPY EMBEDDED, IF THERE
TRULY WAS SPYGATE.
THIS IS DEFLECTION.
WHY DEFLECT FROM THE MUELLER
SPECIAL COUNSEL INVESTIGATION IF
THERE IS NOTHING TO HIDE.
>> Bret: BOTH THINGS ARE GOING
FORWARD.
WE ALWAYS SAY WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
WE DON'T KNOW BUT WE ARE
COVERING BOTH SIDES.
THE REASON I BRING UP THE JARED
KUSHNER THING IS HOW THAT WAS
COVERED EARLY ON IN THE PROCESS
SUGGESTED THAT BECAUSE OF ALL
THE FOREIGN CONTACTS AND ALL THE
QUESTIONS THAT WERE RAISED ABOUT
JARED KUSHNER THAT THERE WAS NO
WAY HE WAS GOING TO GET SECURITY
CLEARANCE AND SOMEHOW HE COULD
BE CHARGED OR INDICTED.
THAT WAS THE COVERAGE AND THE
SPECULATION.
NOW HE'S CLEARED.
>> AS A FORMER OFFICIAL TOLD
CATHERINE HERRIDGE IN HER
REPORT, THAT WOULD IMPLY THAT
THOSE COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
CONCERNS NO LONGER EXIST.
IF HE HAD BEEN GRANTED THE
SECURITY CLEARANCE.
I LIKE TO QUOTE DONALD RUMSFELD.
THERE ARE SO MANY KNOWN
UNKNOWNS.
THE INVESTIGATION INTO RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE IN THE
INVESTIGATION OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
COMING FROM CONGRESS AS MUCH AS
DONALD TRUMP IS PUBLICIZING IT
AND AIDING IT, THERE ARE A LOT
OF CONCERNS FROM THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE ABOUT HOW
DID THIS START.
I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE GREAT
UNKNOWNS.
ONE OF THE GREAT KNOWN UNKNOWNS,
RATHER.
WHILE HE WAS THE ORIGINAL ORDER
THAT DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
ROSENSTEIN GAVE TO ROBERT
MUELLER?
WE DON'T KNOW THE FULL DETAILS.
WE ALSO DON'T KNOW ABOUT THIS
OTHER BRITISH PROFESSOR WHO MET
WITH GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS.
HE HASN'T BEEN SEEN IN PUBLIC IN
MONTHS.
THE KNOWN UNKNOWNS CONTINUE TO
MOUNT.
>> Bret: MARA, WHERE DO YOU
THINK THIS GOES?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
WE KNOW WHAT RUDY GIULIANI SAYS,
THAT IT WILL BE DONE BY
SEPTEMBER.
MUELLER WILL BE DONE BY
THE PROBLEM IS THAT EVERY TWIST
AND TURN, WE DON'T KNOW THE BIG
PICTURE.
BOB MUELLER ISN'T TALKING, TO
HIS CREDIT.
WE ARE COVERING THIS THROUGH A
STRAW AND EVERYTHING SEEMS LIKE
THE BIGGEST DEAL.
I WOULD SAY THE BOTTOM LINE TO
ME FOR TODAY FOR JARED KUSHNER,
THIS WAS A GOOD DAY FOR JARED
KUSHNER AND A GOOD WEEK FOR
JARED KUSHNER BECAUSE HE STARTED
WORKING ON A SUBSTANTIVE POLICY
THAT HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
CONGRESS COMMAND THAT HIS PRISON